[Music]
when you're rihanna and you're putting
together your savagex fenty volume 3
show you get your pick of hollywood's
top stars it was like mind blowing to
celebrate riri's latest visual spectacle
which is now streaming on amazon prime
video et is running down all the biggest
celebrity cameos
it was perfect the show opens with
singer jade nova and several dancers
they show off their moves inside a
structure with different levels i knew
it had to be the space
so many ideas that you could do and
accomplish within a space like that and
we took advantage of all of those that's
when supermodel cindy crawford struts
her way through it was exciting the next
performer bia who sings her tick-tock
hit a whole lot of money i put on my
jury just to go to the bodega and i keep
it with me just so that i'm feeling
safer and normani is there too she
sizzles while singing her song wildside
thank you i work work really hard
madonna's 24 year old daughter lourdes
leone makes an appearance clad in a
skimpy set the model lays seductively on
a circle-shaped bed i think anything's
possible for her she's
way more talented than i am than i was
am whatever so i'm really proud of her
emily ratakowski derobes while exiting a
limo bella porch rocks her signature
pigtails and black lingerie and ricky
martin brings the heat with his song que
rico fuera thank you
clad in a white lingerie set vanessa
hudgins rides in an elevator shortly
after musician jasmine sullivan starts
playing as model irina shakes slithers
around in a snakeskin print number then
daddy yankee revs up the energy on top
of a skyscraper
[Music]
everything that i got in my heart i will
express it in that moment back to inside
sabrina carpenter flaunts a netted
ensemble rupaul's drag race star
gottmick delivers an iconic serve and
erica badu of course in a hat her
signature accessory emerges from an
elevator in a sexy black outfit with
lots of gold jewels erica about do she's
gonna walk the show her and that booty
is gonna be right here and would it
really be a rihanna production without a
rihanna performance no singing but re is
sizzling what was it like doing that you
know that was some sexy choreography
not easy in a corset let me just say
that much i mean but it is savage honey
i know how to make it work the only
thing better than one gigi hadid three
the supermodel looks stunning in this
sparkly blue robe rocking a similar hue
simone the season 13 winner of rupaul's
drag race and props to ballroom icon
laomi who makes a cameo appearance
complete with a death drop
[Music]
nas delivers the final performance of
the show but naturally things close out
with rihanna smiling and giving the
performers a round of applause
and all that clapping is well deserved
when e.t caught up with the designer she
explained the careful thought she puts
into her shows i'm thinking okay so how
do we talk this one
next year you know you're already
thinking about that because that's
really the challenge to make it bigger
and better and more inclusive every year
but
you know we somehow managed to
we managed to pull it off every year
you